hey what's up guys it's Rob and welcome
to my tutorial for the transforming
double ninja stars so I got a comment
recently on my ninja star boomerang from
Nicole and her son Nate asking if it's
possible to connect two of them together
to make a sort of double ninja star
boomerang and well I didn't have much
success with that I wasn't able to come
up with a double ninja star based on
that design I posted a picture of it on
my community tab and it seems most
people really wanted to see it
one comment asked if I just stack two
ninja stars together which is not the
case but today I'm gonna show you how to
make it before we start if you enjoy the
video be sure to give it a thumbs up
down below and also subscribe and click
that notification bell if you haven't
already
we'll need a whole printer sheet to make
it but if you want to use different
colors then you can do that as well so
once you have your paper let's get to it
to make the transforming double ninja
star from a single sheet we'll need to
split it into quarters I'm going to be
using red and blue for this tutorial but
you can use an all-white sheet or
whatever colors you like holding both
sheets and a portrait orientation with
the shorter ends on top and bottom I'm
going to first split the paper in half
by folding the top to the bottom and
then tearing or cutting it we can then
fold them once more and split them into
quarters from the quarters now we're
going to be creating two identical
clockwise locking pieces which I'm
making in blue and look like this and
two identical counterclockwise pieces
which I'm making in red and look like
this as you can see the pieces are
mirror images of one another so let's
start by making the blue clockwise
pieces first and set the rest of the
papers aside to make the first clockwise
piece take the paper and fold it in half
by lining up the two edges just like
this once you line it up just walk your
finger across it and then we can sharpen
the crease by just running our
fingernail against it take the left edge
and fold it across to the right edge
like this once they're lined up then you
can just crease on the left side here
and just make another firm crease open
it up so that it's a mountain fold and
you'll see we divided the paper in half
along this vertical line the right side
and the top edge is going to
folded directly down onto that vertical
line once you do that and you line it up
make a nice sharp crease on the right
side the left side and the bottom edge
is going to be folded up so that this
edge meets that one fold the left edge
up and make a crease on the left side
now then you could flip it upside down
we're going to take this top edge and
fold it down to the bottom by just
taking the paper rounding it off a bit
and folding it so that it meets the
bottom edge then you can once again make
a nice sharp crease on the top and just
run your fingernail against it the
bottom edge here on the bottom right is
going to be folded to the top so just do
the same thing
crease it like this round it off and
line up the edges just like that once
again make a nice sharp crease we're
going to open up these edges and we're
just going to airplane fold these
corners to the middle just like that do
the same on the other side so just
airplane the corners and that the top
edge is on the middle and do the same
with the left side so now your paper
should look like this we're just going
to reclose this bottom right edge by
folding it up like that and giving it a
good pinch and reclose the top left by
just pushing down like that and creasing
it just flatten everything out as you'll
notice we have a diamond here on the
front whereas on the back it's split on
the right side of this dime in this
corner right at this little edge we're
just going to take the bottom right arm
and fold it to the left like this make
sure that this outer edge here lines up
with this one so just fold it like that
and then give it a pinch the top left
arm now is going to be folded to the
right on the same point fold it to the
right like this and then make another
crease then you could flatten everything
out and you've finished the first
clockwise piece you could tell it's
clockwise because the top arm is facing
to the right and the bottom is facing to
the left even if you flip it upside down
we can then make another clockwise piece
and when
finished we then have two identical
pieces the counterclockwise and
clockwise pieces are nearly the same so
let's just fold it down in half first
and then take the left side and again
fold it in half splitting it down the
middle when we open it up to make the
counterclockwise piece the left side
will go down first and then the right
side will be up then we could just make
it the same exact way so just flip it
over top edge goes down here bottom edge
goes up you can open it and airplane
fold these corners in and then you could
reclose these edges the top arm here is
going to go to the left side right at
this point and the bottom is going to go
to the right flatten it out and then you
can make one more and we're done with
all the pieces so make one more
counterclockwise piece and when we're
done we'll have all the pieces we need
now that we finished all four pieces we
can interlock them and just be sure that
you have one set of clockwise pieces and
one set of counterclockwise meaning that
the clockwise one has the top to the
right bottom to the left and the
counterclockwise one is the opposite
with the top to the left and bottom to
the right grab both of your clockwise
pieces now and we're just going to open
it so that the arms are flat like this
take the other one open it up and twist
it like this so that the arms are up and
down and put the diamond on the top on
here over this one just like that then
we're just going to close it in a
clockwise direction so just start with
one of them by going one two then three
and then finally the fourth one goes
over the third one and underneath the
first one so just lift up the first one
right here like this leaving a little
bit of space and then you could round
this off a little bit tuck it into that
little opening and just pull it all the
way through and just make sure
everything is nice and flat you can kind
of tug on each of these arms like this
and then flatten it out now we're going
to take the clockwise an in your star
and flip it upside down and as you'll
see we have a little sleeve here on the
back and it's this sleeve that allows
the other ninja star to kind of lock
into it what we're going to do is just
hold the ninja star like this and you're
going to take one of the
counterclockwise pieces and open it as
you'll see if you look here at the
diamond this edge and this edge are
facing in the upper-right direction like
that now if you take the sleeve and you
hold it like this you'll also see this
edge and this edge are in the same
direction that's the way you want it now
we're going to take the point of the
counterclockwise one slide it underneath
the sleeve here like that and get it
across now if it gets tough in there you
might need to lift the sleeve up a
little bit and work it through but just
slide it all the way up to the diamond
so just pull it through until the
diamond is in line with the sleeve you
see that so you see the edge is right
next to the edge of the sleeve on the
back just like that that's how you want
it we are interlocking the
counterclockwise one now so take the
other red one and open it up hold it on
top so that the arms are flat horizontal
place it right in the middle of that
sleeve like that so that the corners of
the diamond line up with the corners
right here now we're going to lock it in
a counterclockwise direction so doesn't
matter which one you take just take one
and then we're going this way to 3 and
then finally the fourth one again goes
over here and under there so just lift
up the first one and then hold this down
like that round it off and slide it
right into that opening right there then
just flatten everything out make sure
everything's nice and flat and there you
go you have finished the double
transforming ninja star just flatten it
out really well and then to make it
transform
as you could see it looks like this one
ninja star but if you turn it
counterclockwise by just taking both
your hands and just turning it like this
you'll see it will kind of shift like
that and you can move it around a little
bit like that you see it might twist a
little better in certain ways and then
you can also put it back and then twist
it clockwise if you want like that see
that worked a little bit better so one
way might twist a little nicer than the
other like that and then you could twist
it back so there you go there is your
double transforming ninja star to throw
it I found that it flies a little bit
better if you hold it like this with the
points facing up to the right and then
you flick it out like a frisbee
let's throw two at the same time whoa
thanks again for watching my tutorial
for the transforming double ninja star I
hope you guys enjoyed it as much as I
did I think it's really cool if you did
like it be sure to give it a thumbs up
down below and don't forget to subscribe
and click the notification bell and
leave me a comment down below let me
know what you thought of the
transforming double ninja star and what
you might like to see next I hope you're
all enjoying your summer I've been
getting a lot of Sun as you guys can
tell I've been going out a lot on the
water on my new jetski to some of the
islands around me in the water and I've
seen a lot of different wildlife he's
only 17 back and caught some fish also
but this one unfortunately was not a
keeper
thanks again for all the support and
I'll see you soon